Good morning, everyone.
To start with, I'm going to talk about how we can assess the financial strength of a bank.
What do we mean by strength?
How do we measure this?
Well, we can look at a comparative analysis;...
...that is, how the particular bank compares with other banks,..
...or how it compares with its own performance in previous years.
In this lecture, I'm going to focus on individual bank performance and...
...the bank we will be looking at is the ANW Bank.
I'll use the financial accounts in the shareholders' report,...
...which contains two tables of interest to us.
These are the statement of financial performance and the statement of financial position.
While both these documents provide different information on the bank's financial strength,...
...the statement of financial position is arguably the document...
...for understanding the state of the bank's finances.
The main discussion will be on the statement of financial position.
Firstly, I'll define exactly what a statement of financial position is.
Then I'll briefly go over the categories included in a statement of financial position.
I'll start with assets followed by liabilities.
After that, I'll look at equity.
Finally, I'll talk briefly about the statement of financial performance.
This shows the movements in income, expenditure and profit...
...which have taken place since the end of the previous accounting period.
In other words, it shows the trading results for 12 months.